So, I want to show you one more
thing. Here, we have two loops. This one arranges
the pictures. The one over here draws the
pictures. Now, the second loop is so simple and
so common, that there is a shorthand for
it called the enhanced for loop. Instead of letting
the index value, i, go from zero, through
all the valid values. And then using the index,
to get the ith picture, you can do the
following. You can simply write for, then you make a
variable for the picture. Then you write a colon, and
then the array list that you want to traverse. This loop
sets pic to the first element in the gallery.
Or I guess I should say the zeroth element, then
to the element within index one, then to the element
with index two, and so on. So pic assumes and
turn all of the values off the array list each time the loop is entered
and in this case, pic is drawn. You could do other things as well, of course.